Now let's talk about what
happens in a write back cache.
Write through is fairly simple.
We just send writes to memory and
the cache works just as
we described it before.
But for write back caches,
we can have a block that we did write
since we last brought
it from the memory.
In that case, when we replace the block
we need to write it to memory, but
we can have a block that we didn't write
since we last brought it from memory.
That block has only been
read since we brought it in.
In that case,
when we replace, there is no need
to write that block back to memory.
But how do we know which
one of these we have?
One choice that we might make
is that we don't want to know.
We'll just every time that
we replace the block.
Unfortunately, there is a lot of
read only stuff that we will now
end up writing to memory over and
over, all that's unnecessary.
So instead, we choose to add a dirty
bit to every block in the cache.
The dirty bit says
whether we have written
the block since it was
placed in the cache, or not.
So if the dirty bit is zero,
it means that the block is clean, or
it was not written since it
was last brought from memory.
Or, we can have the dirty bit be one,
in which case we say that the block is
dirty, or it was written since
we last brought it from memory.
And that means that we need to
write this block back to memory
on replacement.
When this block is kicked out of the
cache it needs to be written to memory.
If it's claim then we don't
have to write it to memory.